what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with another installment
of our beyond omega level series where
we cover the most powerful characters in
comics and today we're talking about
perhaps spider-man's most deadly villain
the red goblin now the first appearance
of the red goblet occurred in the
amazing spider-man number 798 by dan
slott and stewart imminent of course
this was in 2018 during dan's slot's
final story arc of his long run and
amazing run on amazing spider-man and
basically what happens is that norman
osborne which of course is the real name
of the green goblin one of spider-man's
oldest and most bitter enemies is
basically sick of losing to spider-man
all the time so he decides he's going to
find a way to fight and defeat his
archrival so he steals the carnage
symbiote from a shield warehouse now i'm
pretty sure all of you know what the
carnage symbiote is but in case you
don't i'll give you the extremely
condensed version so spider-man is taken
to a planet called battle world by a guy
called the beyonder where he's basically
bonded with an alien symbiote that he
would eventually abandon which made the
symbiote pretty pissed off later the
symbiote would bond to eddie brock who
was also pissed off at spider-man and in
their mutual hatred they became venom
and when sharing a jail cell with a
serial killer named cletus cassidy the
venom symbiote basically left behind an
offspring which bonded with cletus and
then became carnage now something else
that i want to point out here is that
spider-man had also taken away norman
osborne's ability to become the green
goblin and so in truth the hope of
norman osborn was to bond with the
carnage symbiote in order to restore his
ability to become the green goblin the
other part of that is that norman had a
really hard time controlling the
symbiont because it was basically
motivated by a desire to kill as many
people as possible but he's eventually
able to reason with the symbiote as it
allows him to have more control so that
he can put his plan to kill spider-man
in motion but after his memory is jogged
so that he remembers spider-man's secret
identity norman osborn confronts peter
parker at the daily bugle as the red
goblin and basically tells them that if
he doesn't stop operating as spider-man
he'll kill everyone that's important to
peter and when i say everyone i mean
like everyone now norman also takes a
piece of the carded symbiote and then
merges it with his grandson normie to
create the goblin child which is
essentially just a small version of the
red goblin and it's just really as
creepy looking as it sounds it really is
now norman also plants a piece of the
carnage symbiote inside of peter's loved
ones and threatens that he can command
these pieces of the symbiote to kill
their hosts at any point in time but
flash thompson is able to save mary jane
and aunt may by removing the pieces of
the carnate symbiote now the red
goblin's quest to defeat spider-man
comes to a head when the two of them
battle in times square while peter's
wearing the venom symbiote and while red
goblin gains the advantage at first
spider-man is able to mess with his head
by getting norman to doubt his own
abilities by pointing out that he needed
the carnage symbiote in order to win and
so the battle ends with spider-man using
a gas tank to destroy the carnage
symbiote and the whole ordeal causes
norman to go insane and think that he
actually is cletus cassidy while
spider-man is norman osborne now as for
his powers they come from two very
different sources obviously the carnage
symbiote is one of those sources but
it's also enhanced by the goblin serum
now the goblin serum was the substance
that first transformed osborne into the
green goblin which granted him a variety
of powers like superhuman strength speed
stamina and reflexes as well as a
moderate healing factor now even before
being injected with the serum norman
osborne was pretty intelligent but the
serum took his intelligence to the next
level and he basically became a genius
however this boost to his intelligence
comes with a drawback in that the serum
also seems to cause norman osborne to
become mentally unstable to the point of
insanity now as we mentioned at one
point norman lost the abilities granted
to him by the goblin serum after dr
octopus as superior spider-man injected
him with an anti-serum that counteracts
its effects but upon merging with a
carnot symbiote the anti-serum is purged
from his system and the green goblin is
able to work again but we also have the
carnage symbiote giving norman osborne
powers as well so most notably this is
going to make norman osborne even
stronger faster and more durable than he
is with the goblin serum and just in
terms of physical strength carnage is
said to be stronger than spider-man and
venom combined now the carnage symbiote
is also capable of shape-shifting and
its hosts frequently use this ability to
turn their appendages into weapons like
axes or swords and also mimic
spider-man's web slinging abilities now
the red goblin in particular uses this
ability to recreate his goblin glider
which he uses to fly around and an
updated version of his famous pumpkin
bombs that he very creatively names
carnage bombs and which actually seem to
have somewhat of a mind of their own
with the capability to speak and to bite
their victims he can also heal most
injuries instantaneously including the
loss of his limbs now traditionally the
carnot symbiote has had a weakness to
fire and sound but the red goblin does
not seem to share these weaknesses as
he's routinely been near fire with no
ill effects and can even breathe fire
for some reason it's never really
explained but he can however he does
retain one of carnage's traditional
weaknesses which is the touch of the
anti-venom symbiote which was worn by
flash thompson during this storyline now
it's time to address the elephant in the
room the thing you've probably been
thinking ever since you clicked on this
video is red goblin really omega level
and to that i answer an emphatic maybe
does he have the feats to be considered
omega level probably not but he does
have impressive feats he's defeated some
incredibly powerful opponents including
venom anti-venom miles morales silk and
doc ock he's even defeated the human
torch which is definitely his most
impressive feat since the human torch is
beyond omega level in his own right but
is taking him out enough to make a
character omega level or beyond probably
not but could the red goblin
theoretically do something that would
cause us to consider him omega level and
the answer to that is yes now he's not
going to destroy the planet in the
traditional sense by blowing it up he's
not that sort of a threat but that's not
to say he couldn't destroy everyone
living on the planet in fact i think he
could in much the same way that he
threatened to kill mary jane and aunt
may by sending fragments of the carnage
symbiote into their brain he could
theoretically do the same thing to
everybody in the world would that take
some extensive planning by someone with
a very keen and genius level intellect
sure but norman osborne fits that bill
he's smart enough and cruel enough to
pull something like that off and if he's
going to wipe out all of the human life
on the planet then i don't think that's
a big stretch to call him omega level
now it is a little bit of a stretch to
calm omega level in general but hey work
with me here guys work with me with that
being said we're gonna bring this to an
end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace